Do you have any objections or comments on the treatments proposed for me at the Immunotherapy
Institute in Tijuana?
So this person sent me a proposal from this Mexico cancer clinic in Tijuana, what they
want to do for her.
No, I think it looks great and if you feel led to go down there and do that, there's a lot
of different, you know, semi-invasive therapies that could be really great.
So I looked over it early this morning and I thought it was a great bit.
So do I think for you specifically, is it necessary where you're at right now?
No, but I mean, again, if you feel led to do that, then by all means to do that, I don't
know if you made the step to talk to the surgeon yet, if you had that appointment, whether
that, how that went, whether they're going to do a lump back to me, or they're still
pushing you for a mastectomy, I don't know.
So if you're planning on doing the Tijuana visit prior to that, or you're going to go do
the surgery, do the lump back to me, or are they pushing you for a mastectomy, I don't know.
But I did like their proposal and looked great.
Do I think you particularly, I need to do that?
No, but if you feel led to that, I don't see anything, any problem with that whatsoever.